wanna know what time theater this  weekend powerful men don't have to be  cruel I had a plan Ben Affleck breaks  all the rules as a 1920s mobster and  lived by night with the events of the  Boston Marathon bombing a policeman's  work begins in Patriots day the world is  watching  we gotta find these guys before they do  this is someone else if I tell you about  him you're all dead in the bye-bye man  three friends accidentally unleash a  terrifying supernatural and finally  let's find out what's hot in theaters  this weekend with this week's fantasy  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket  [Music]